esta carretera vereda es la que utilizan
la mayoría de personas que huyen de
gerson ese puerto sobre el mar negro que
cayó en control de las fuerzas rusas al
comienzo de la guerra el 24 de febrero y
que se convirtió en la primera gran
ciudad de ucrania en caer en control del
ejército ruso aquí nos cuentan que cada
cierto tiempo 30 o 40 automóviles pasan
por aquí aquí hay un retén que él donde
le revisan sus papeles y que no vengan
infiltrados de los rusos para entrar al
resto de ucrania pero nos dicen que
muchas más personas en los últimos días
quieren huir pero se los impiden según
la inteligencia ucraniana hay mil 500
automóviles en el último retén ruso
esperando cruzar hasta esta parte del
país porque la situación allí además de
ser insoportable por la situación
económica también lo es por la seguridad
desde hace semanas los rusos están
imponiendo el rublo como moneda local lo
que hace que todo en él en esta ciudad
sea mucho más costoso también hay
escasez porque los productos los tienen
que traer de crimea y no hay medicinas
hay pocos vegetales
además la seguridad muchas de las
viviendas son saqueadas especialmente de
aquellos que dejaron la ciudad
automóviles que son robados y dicen que
no tanto lo hacen los integrantes del
ejército ruso sino muchas de las
milicias que trabajan con ellos